hey guys you know in entertainment
unbelievers usually show Christian men
as a weird cult weird spineless weak men
it cannot be further than the truth
Christian men are some of the most
strongest men that you will ever find in
this world especially mature Christians
why
because they have an edge on unbelievers
the natural person with only their soul
level
what is that edge it is God's spirit in
them God is in their Corner 2 Timothy 1
verse 7 says for God gave us a spirit
not of fear but of power and love and
self-control and one Corinthians 16 13
says Be watchful stand firm in the faith
act like men
and that is why I have this Christian
merch on today man up in the biblical
sense of what it means to man up
it says act like men and then be strong
now this is not that kind of strength
where you try to persuade yourself that
you are powerful oh I'm a strong man you
puff yourself up in your arrogance on
your soul level
that's what unbelievers do no the
strength I'm talking about is Inner
Strength that comes from God himself
through his power it's not a
self-confidence thing it is a god
confidence thing I'll talk about this a
little bit more later on
I want to make this video very
interesting and entertaining in showing
you the top fiercest and strongest
Warriors of the Bible
you know when you watch movies and you
see one guy taking on three or four you
think wow that guy is pretty good and
when they bring out movies with great
warriors like the movie 300 that's a
good example you think wow these men
were great they were Fearless strong
the men I'm talking about in the Bible
are a lot stronger those men of the 300
they don't even come close to the top
seven strongest Warriors of the bible
let me tell you some War Stories let's
start with the first one
number seven Jonathan and his armor
Bearer
1 Samuel 14 13. then Jonathan climbed up
on his hands and feet and his armor
Bearer after him
and they fell before Jonathan
and his armor Bearer killed him after
him and that first strike which Jonathan
and his armor Bearer made killed about
20 men within as it were half a
Pharaoh's length in acre of land
two guys against many and they defeat 20
in the first goal that's something
special number six banaya
in 2 Samuel 23 verse 20 we read and
binaya the son of jehoida
was a valiant man of kabziel a doer of
great Deeds
he struck down two Aerials of Moab what
are these two Aerials of Moab they are
famous and fierce Warriors the King
James says he slew to lion-like Men of
Moab now that's interesting isn't it
were they some sort of Nephilim half
breeds you know half human half demon
well we don't know but it goes on and it
says this verse 21 Amplified version and
he killed an Egyptian an impressive and
handsome man the Egyptian had a spear in
his hand but banaya went down to him
with a club
snatched the spear out of the Egyptian's
hand and kill the man with his own spear
these things banaya the son of jehoiah
did and gained a reputation beside the
three Mighty Men He was honored among
the thirty but he did not attain to the
greatness of the three David appointed
him over his guard
now this is interesting we see that
there are ranks between the Warriors and
we see that there are the top 30. these
guys were impressive by then there are
the top three who are these three Mighty
Warriors
well let's take a look
number five Joseph bashebeth
Tucson Mill 23 verse 8. these are the
names of the Mighty Men whom David had
he was chief of the three he wielded his
spear against 800 whom he killed at one
time
wow 800 men at one time
this was a great warrior
number four Eleazar
which is basically the next verse and
next to him among the three Mighty Men
was Eleazar the son of Dodo son of ahohi
he was with David when they defied the
Philistines who were gathered there for
battle
and the men of Israel withdrew
Heroes and struck down to Philistines
until his hand was wary and his hand
clung to The Sword and the Lord brought
about a great victory that day and the
men returned after him only to strip the
slain
wow this is amazing Israel withdrew but
this guy he just went and he just
continued to fight and he beat them
I don't even know how many men he had to
kill but just imagine this for a second
what a powerful man
slaying so many that he could not let go
of his sword
wow number three shamgar
Judges 3 verse 31. after him was shamgar
the son of anath who killed 600 of the
Philistines with an ox goat and he also
saved Israel
that's it that's the only sentence we
get about shamgar we don't get anything
else that's all we know about him and
that's why a lot of people miss this
information about shamgar if you talk to
a lot of Christians today you ask them
hey who is shamgar in the Bible
a lot of people will say well I don't
know
shamgar was one of the great judges
who took over after eud another judge
who led the nation of Israel
he was great he didn't just kill 10 or
20 people but 600 with an ox goat he was
a great warrior and that is why we are
including him in our first game called
judges TD
you can get more information about it in
the video description down below
number two Samson
Samson was unbelievably strong I mean
who does not know about Samson right
most of us grew up with stories about
Samson
he was
he was something else
he killed a lion with his bare hands
judges 14 verse 5. he killed 1 000
Philistines with only the Jawbone of a
donkey
judges 15 15.
he also slayed 30 Philistines at ascalon
in judges 14 19.
and he even carried the Big Iron Gate of
Gaza and carried it 30 miles to the top
of a hill near Hebron
man I just get tired of climbing a big
hill and running a little bit but Samson
he broke off these huge I mean big iron
gates and he walked with them 30 miles
and then after that he climbed the hill
to the top with it as well it's
unbelievable why was he so strong
because he just believed in his own
power
no he was strong because of God for
example judges 14 verse 5 says then
Samson went down with his father and
mother to timna and they came to The
Vineyards of timna
and behold a young lion came toward him
roaring then the spirit of the Lord
rushed upon him and although he had
nothing in his hand
he tore the lion in pieces as one tears
a young goat
wow he said jaw-drop moment right
imagine if you see that happening right
in front of you
it's unbelievable
Samson
was a great warrior and that is why we
are also going to include him in our
game actually let's make it interesting
let me show you a sneak peek of Samson
in the game judges TD
[Music]
thank you
pretty cool isn't it all right let's
continue number one is David
by now most of you know about David
right you've probably already heard
about the stories about David this
Warrior Fearless who came and slayed
Goliath the giant a lot of men were
cowering
I can just imagine how I would feel
standing there looking at Goliath and
thinking Hmm
I don't know
but here David goes and is there's
something different about David
he also led the nation of Israel to
Victory many victories over the
Philistines ammonites
moabite and many others
why was David so special
a man that is great there was something
different about David what was it I mean
the Bible says in 1 Samuel 18 14 David
acted wisely and prospered in all his
ways and the Lord was with him
you see that is the key he acted wisely
and God was with him you see he knew
that he is a lot stronger with God at
his side not trying to do things on his
own but living righteously seeking the
heart of God that is God confidence not
self-confidence and that is why we read
in Acts 13 22 he raised up David to be
their King whom he testified and said I
have found in David the son of Jesse a
man after my heart who will do all my
will
who will do all my will did you get that
wow imagine God says this about you
that you are a man after God's Own Heart
do you want him to say that
well then let me ask you
do you do his will
do you walk within his plan and purpose
for your life like David did
you cannot just be a hearer of his word
and not a doer James 1 22 says but be
doers of the word and not hearers only
deceiving yourselves for if anyone is a
hearer of the word another doer he is
like a man who looks intently at his
natural face in a mirror for he looks at
himself and goes away and at once
forgets what he was like but the one who
looks into the perfect law the law of
Liberty and perseveres being no hearer
who forgets but a doer who acts
he will be blessed in his doing
this is what it means to be a man of
your God's Own Heart
this is how you can be a strong Warrior
through Christ that gives you strength
and make no mistake you are already in
the battle whether you like it or not we
are in a spiritual battle and you need
to put on the armor of God and fight
Ephesians 6 verse 11 put on the whole
armor of God that you may be able to
stand against the schemes of the devil
and Ephesians 6 12 says for we do not
wrestle against the flesh and blood but
against the rulers against the
authorities against the cosmic Powers
over this present Darkness
against the spiritual forces of evil in
the Heavenly places
there are far too many
fat and lazy Christian men in the world
they go to church they go to Bible
studies they get all the spiritual food
week in week out and they do nothing
with it so they get spiritually fat and
lazy
what do you do for God
have you been looking at the world
recently look at the world how evil is
taking over because so many Christian
men are doing nothing
if you see wrong unrighteousness in the
world as a true reborn Christian a man
of the Living God you need to expose it
because that's what light does light
exposes that which is in darkness
Ephesians 5 11 says take no part in the
unfruitful works of darkness
and here it comes so listen closely but
instead
expose them
now to all you men who think you're
Christians and you're not spiritually
reborn it is very dangerous if you go in
the name of God and you try to expose
and just judge people left and right
through your fleshly nature because you
will do a lot more harm than good but if
God leads you
to act in the spirit then you need to
obey him
the armor of God is not there for you so
that you can sit on the sidelines and do
nothing and just comment here from your
phone
you know I see a lot of Christians
comment on Ministries and they complain
they say oh what about this why are you
doing this and well what are you doing
for the kingdom evil is taking over in
certain areas causing suffering
that that's unnecessary
because we are supposed to be the light
in the world to help the poor to help
the weak but a lot of Christian men are
doing nothing you are called to be the
light of the world and to go and make
disciples of all people Matthew 28 verse
19 go therefore and Make Disciples of
all Nations baptizing them in the name
of the father and the son and of the
Holy Spirit
there is a battle going on for souls and
you see if you truly are a reborn
Christian then you love God with your
whole heart and soul and if you do
really love him you will also love other
people because he's Love In You
you can't stop it
you have that love that Agape
unconditional love for other people as
well you hate their sin but you love
people and you want them to be saved
how can you keep the message of the
Gospel to yourself that is
selfish
if you truly love other people then you
would not want them
to go to hell for all eternity to lose
their souls for all eternity
you see our real battle is not physical
it is spiritual against the devil and
his demons 1 Peter 5 verse 8 be sober
minded Be watchful your adversary the
devil prowls around like a roaring lion
seeking someone to devour
in the Old Testament in the time of the
Israelites they had to defend their own
Nation to defend the birth of the
Messiah you see the devil and his demons
was using other nations to try and stop
the birth of the Messiah who is Jesus
Christ who would come was prophesized to
come not just to save the nation of
Israel but to save the whole world
and you see
he did come he already died for our sins
on the cross so that we might be free
he is already Victorious and we are
victorious through Jesus Christ one
Corinthians 15 57 but thanks be to God
who gives us the victory through our
Lord Jesus Christ and Romans 8 37 says
no in all these things we are more than
conquerors through him who loved us
you see the devil already knows that
he's been defeated now he's just angry
that's why he's walking around like a
roaring lion looking at someone who can
who he can devour he's trying to drag as
many humans with him into hell
God saved you and now with the time that
he has still given you that you have
left here on this temporary world you
need to use to shine your light so that
you can save others
and you need to use the spiritual
weapons that he gave you 2 Corinthians
10 verse 3 to 5 for though we walk in
the flesh we are not Waging War
according to the flesh for the weapons
of our Warfare are not of the flesh but
have divine power to destroy strongholds
we destroy arguments and every lofty
opinion raised against the knowledge of
God and take every thought captive to
obey Christ
Now put on the armor of God and use it
wisely to fight through the spirit do
not be distracted by temporary Earthly
things that do not even matter
when we look at the Eternal things the
things above
you know a lot of Christians spend their
time on things that does not matter
and the devil is laughing because
he is distracting you
think right now how many people that you
know are still unsaved
and maybe for some of you the things
that you think about is oh this person
needs to need to do this and this car
needs to go and he needs to go to that
person and do that Earthly things what
about spiritual things what about their
souls
pray about them for them and let God
lead you to save their souls
Paul said in 1 Corinthians 9 19 for
though I am free from all I have made
myself a servant to all that I might win
more of them
to the Jews I became as a Jew in order
to win Jews to those under the law I
became as one under the law though not
being myself under the law that I might
win those under the law
to those outside the law I became as one
outside the law not being outside the
law of God but under the law of Christ
that I might win those outside the law
do you understand what he's saying here
he is connecting with people on their
level so that he can share the gospel to
them effectively but a lot of you
Christians out there are
arrogant
you don't want to change to share the
gospel I'm not saying that we have to
compromise the word of God I'm saying we
have to preach it in Truth in love but
there are ways that you can do it to
different types of people to share it
more effectively verse 22 to the weak I
became weak that I might win the week I
have become all things to all people
that by all means I might save some
I do it all for the sake of the Gospel
that I may share with them in its
blessings some of you out there are too
stubborn stuck in your old ways your
comfort zone
and because you are so stuck and not
willing to change and to connect with
people on their level
they are not hearing the gospel from you
people around you cannot find God
because you are not even trying to
connect with them at their level
you judge in Anger instead of sharing
the gospel in Truth and Love A lot of
people do not like the truth especially
when we talk about sins and hell and you
know it depends on on what the Holy
Spirit leads us to talk about
people feel guilty they don't want their
Darkness to be exposed but that is what
the gospel does the truth of the Gospel
and it doesn't mean that you shouldn't
share the gospel because now people feel
uncomfortable you should share it but
there is a way to share it effectively
in love where they know this person is
sharing this with me because they
actually really do care about me they
love me they don't want me to be lost so
it's what they are saying actually true
you see that's where the gospel is
powerful when you share it through the
spirit through truth and through love
those of you who are still stubborn in
your old ways
you might not even realize this but
you're doing it through your flesh
you're not doing it through the spirit
what are you doing
your weapons are supposed to be the
gifts of the Spirit Galatians 5 verse 22
but the fruit of the spirit is love
Joy
peace
patience
kindness
goodness
faithfulness
gentleness
self-control
against such things there is no law now
to understand this more please watch
this series that I covered on the fruit
of the spirit and I'll see you there and
before you go always remember God loves
you and I love you too bye